[موسيقى]
انه لا معقول اصلا فكره مجنونه انه معقول
انا
بيع يعني ما تخيلت
ابدا اسمي فيرونيكا نمر عمري 23 سنه وانا
صاحبه مشروع حزك مزك حزك مزك هي كلمه
بتعني عن عن انه رايحه وجايه بنفس الاتجاه
بس كذا مره هي بستعملها بالكلام العفوي
اللبناني وطلع ولقيته كثير بيلبق على اللي
انا الشي اللي بدي
اعمله من اكثر من سنه ونص بلشت اشتغل بكذا
مجال اجاني قافر على رومانيا كان كثير غير
عن ما انه انا توقعته فقررت انه ارجع على
بلدي ولو كان الوضع منه مستقر
بلبنان وقتها رجعت على بلدتي بلبنان سقب
شفت
نفسان الخضره اللي صارله من انا وصغيره
ببيع بيبرم على الحي وببيع خضره وفواكه
طلعت فيه وهيك اجاني هي الهام فجاه انه
ليه ما انا بيع خره وفواكه بس ببيروت لا
ما في حدا بيعمل
هيك اول ما قي الهامه انه خلص هي هي اللي
بدي اعمله ما كن بعرف سوقان ما كان مع
سواقه ما
كان بعرف بالقطاع الزراعي ابدا فهيدي
الصعوبات مرقت مرقت علي بس قدرت
اعملها حطيت براسي انه بدي انبسط بالشيء
اللي عم بعمله بدي اتصلى بدي اعيش كل يوم
بيومه وهذا اللي صار وكنت كثير عم احط
طاقه ايجابيه بالشي اللي عم بعمله انا وعم
ابيع مع الموسيقى راقس مع العالم ضحك حضه
الضحكه اللي هي كثير بسيطه بس هي مفوله
كثير
كبير كل شي كان عم بينعمل بطريقه كثير
عفويه يعني انا كنت عن جد عم احط الكاميرا
قدامي وعم اصور بس اللي عم بصير لرالي شو
عم بصير الحقيقه بلا اديتينج بلا بلا شي
انا بحس هيدا هو الشي اللي خل العالم تحب
اللي عم بصير وتعيش مع اللي عم بصير وتكون
هيك
قريبه وبتعرف شو عم بصير اكثر او شو هو
حزك مزك بالضبط رسالتي ل كل الشباب
ولكل
البنات اللي بفكروا يبلشوا بشيء بس مخوفهم
بتوقفهم او اللي حواليهم اوق وقفوهم ما في
حدا بيقف بوجهنا اذا نحنا عن جد قررنا انه
بدنا نعمل شي بدنا نبلش شي او بدنا نكتشف
حالنا بدنا نحط حالنا
n